retour en france avec le parquet de
nanterre qui a ouvert une enquête contre
le préfet de police de paris enquête
pour faux témoignage devant la
commission d' enquête sur l'indépendance
de la justice à l'assemblée nationale le
préfet de police de paris est accusé de
ne pas avoir dit la vérité lorsqu'il a
déclaré je cite ne pas avoir trouvé les
organisateurs des manifestations
policières non autorisé en juin dernier
plusieurs hauts magistrats soient
également visé par cette enquête à ce
sujet écouter le député la france a sont
visés président cette commission
ugo bernalicis c'est une bonne nouvelle
en soi une enquête soit ouverte alors ça
sera à charge et à décharge ne serait
pas quelle sera l'issue est à la limite
peu importe l'issue l'objectif pour le
parlementaire que je suis le président
de commission denquête que j'étais sur
les obstacles indépendance du pouvoir
judiciaire
c'est que on prenne au sérieux la
représentation nationale la santé
nationaux ce qu'est une commission
denquête parce que qui on peut venir
devant une commission denquête mentir et
repartir comme si de rien n'était enfin
tout ça ne sert plus à rien on est quand
même la représentation nationale les
gens lèvent la main disait prête serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité
eh bien il faut que ce soit le cas